the oyster is a great thing to eat we
should eat more oysters right she more
clams Florida oddly is an amazing
sustainable seafood scene you know just
the work that they do with the the
Florida stone crab right you know that
every year they just harvest like the
left arm and then they put the crab back
and the next year it's the right arm and
they put the crab back really that's a
brilliant fishing industry yes
don't kill the animal Vick or the flick
claw grows back right and it's nicely in
the plate side by side I don't like that
you're telling me something good about
Florida great shrimping scene a great
you know they're they're actually
leaders in sustainable seafood
well the seafood and fishing is such a
gigantic part of their economy it makes
sense that they would do that that's a
smart thing yeah the grouper fishing
down there is a giant giant part of the
earth there's a good book that was
published a few years ago the big oyster
I think Marco Lansky he wrote a book
about history of the oyster yeah the New
York and the history of the oyster and
it incredible super interesting because
his his thing was like you know we try
to portray our history as like glorious
and we herded Bisons before for protein
and that's how he started I like modern
farming but in fact we probably farmed
oysters and snails and clams because
they don't move and they're the most
prolific and the most abundant source of
protein
Laskey in that book orlansky brings up a
premise and i'm loosely interpreting it
now because i read this book a few years
ago but think of this for a second
right the island of Manhattan is a
perfect all the rivers around it all the
water systems around it is actually one
of the greater oyster situations on the
Atlantic east coast right the reason
that the population exploded in
Manhattan at them in the early days was
that any person could literally get off
a boat walk on to the island of em of
Manhattan homeless broke and sleep in an
alley and walk down to the river and
picked five oysters a small oyster is
five grams of protein right a medium
oysters got ten grams
protein so a completely destitute person
could just eat six oysters a day you
know three oysters and live again
another day to find a job so the
population ultimately you know New York
City and his population was based on
this readily supply for this huge supply
of oysters Wow yeah there's a free
available source of protein that will
make you live another 24 hours so if it
takes you three days to find a job four
days to find a job 20 days to find a job
you're not gonna die because there's
Auster's look at this and yet and they
they found ways for him what is this
Harlem River oh yeah
there's an actual island that they
thought we're like geological formation
that are made of oyster shells this
layers and layers of oyster shells the
article that Jamie put up is from
Thrillist is that what it's from pull up
to the top so he told people the order
of the neighborhood's why or sirs are
ridiculously important to the history of
New York City and it's just showing all
these ancient photos of mounds of oyster
shells there's an amazing program today
you know some of the area's a there's a
they take these giant cages one Easter
if I'm correct one Easter filters four
metric tons of water per day from what I
understand I might be wrong with my math
so take this for instance you know a
cage a caged box of thousands of oysters
there it is there's a single oyster can
filter about 30 to 50 gallons of water
loose bath New York's waterways are
exactly clean as the folks behind the
billion oyster project are trying to
change that by recycling shells from the
partnering restaurants and getting them
back in the water to build austere reefs
the goal is to add a billion moister to
the water by 2035
so far they've restored 1.0 one acre 1.5
acres of reason what don't say 1.05
[ __ ] you got an acre oh that's you just
add in those extra two numbers 1.05
acres of reefs and count 11.5 million
newly grown oysters but the oyster will
clarify the water it'll make
murky River clear again Wow but in
effect the taste of the oyster they
don't eat those oysters I think those
are pulled back into landfill after or
mulched into Gardens or for the shells
mm to be put for more reefs but the
oyster is interesting it doesn't move
right a noise it opens its shells to
feed showing how they do it this is
incredible and the oyster you know that
the oyster has a it will change gender
according to the density of the
population so it'll go from male to
female in order to balance the
flocculation er that's incredible we're
watching a video where the what is it
the oyster recovery so it's a time-lapse
but it said what does it say it was
firmly sure filtration right but there
was a watermark on the video there in
the corner it was showing the recovery
partners yeah so the watermark is so
what they do is they have this horrible
green water they chuck these oysters and
it turns it completely clear that's
amazing I did not know that I did know
that they used to eat lobsters and they
thought of lobsters as poor people food
sure yeah yeah in New Brunswick they
used to harvest the lobsters to feed to
the prisoners and keep the shells as
fertilizer
this person was one of the first
presidents to bring the lobster into the
White House because it was seen as a
servant's food when did it switch
Jefferson so when he started doing that
that's what people realized it was so
delicious
no that's made a lot socially if we
changed the whole thing the lobster
spaghetti that's that's off the chart
you know so the child labor laws
we're in stored primarily because of the
kids that used to work in noiser
shucking plants really yeah yeah we had
a one of our best friend if not our best
friend passed away like six months ago
John bill he was a great talker you
helped us at the bar but he's like deep
into sustainability and history of
oysters and everything and he was like
the source for oysters for everything he
wrote a beautiful book yeah almost send
you a copy it's an incredible book there
are good food for vegans to consider too
because they're more primitive than most
plants ya know smallest John used to
call them ocean cupcakes
well they're delicious it's a great
source of protein but it's also they
don't have any nerve endings and they're
not feeling any it's a sea vegetable
yeah it basically is we have an issue or
some people not myself but some people
have an issue with things that are
capable of moving yeah for whatever
reason we just decide that don't eat
that but if you want to talk about
something sustainable like mollusks and
seafood I mean they can be commercially
farmed they actually do have a positive
impact as you're describing on the
environment incredible source of protein
as well yeah yeah and really Oh a
complete source of protein not like a
very bioavailable source unlike a lot of
vegetable proteins